[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée à l'amour à la passion des
jardins avec deux amoureux de passionnés
des jardins césar garçons bonjour
bonjour bonjour photographes alors vous
c'est l'amour des jardins et l'amour des
des images aussi et vous publiez un
magnifique livre qui s'appelle la
belgique desjardins c'est aux éditions
ulmer
et puis un amoureux des jardins
évidemment et des mots parce que vous
êtes non seulement jardinier en chef du
domaine de versailles nous est aussi
écrivain et vous aviez publié un
dictionnaire amoureux des jardins c'est
alain baraton
il faut chaud du dictionnaire amoureux
des jardins et là il ya une édition a
peu augmenté si je peux dire c'est le
dictionnaire illustré desjardins qui
gronde et plomb alors justement ben j'ai
eu 2 concédant une citation qui commence
votre votre livre
et qui dit les amateurs de jardins sont
réputé paisible on les imagine mal
échangé des coups de sécateurs donc vous
n'allez pas échangé des coups de
sécateurs entre vous il n'y a aucune
raison que je ne crois pas que les
jardiniers est un mauvais esprit
césar est un amoureux pas seulement du
jardin ou de la photographier c'est un
amoureux de la vie et je crois que c'est
ce qui caractérise tous les jardiniers
ils sont amoureux de la vie vous le dit
d'ailleurs à l'amour des jardins c'est
d'abord un jardin c'est un jardin c'est
pas bien parce qu'il est bien cultiver
parce qu'il est beau parce qu'il ya des
belles fleurs c'est parce qu'il a une
âme il a une âme un jardin c'est un lieu
où l'on aime se retrouver un jardin
c'est un lieu que l'on quitte à regret
un jardin c'est un endroit que l'on aime
transmettre
quand on est prêt à le prendre comme ici
chez césar que constate-t-on des arbres
qui ont été plantés par quelqu'un il ya
peut-être 20 30 50 ans même si la
personne n'est plus l'esprit de cette
personne continue d'exister
il ya peut-être des enfants qui jouent
dans ce jardin qui dans 10 15 ou 20 ans
à nouveau profiteront de ce lieu c'est
ça le bonheur du jardin c'est ça le rêve
et la magie du jardin c'est un garçon
justement on va feuilleter le livre avec
ces images sublimes 1 de votre livre sur
la belgique desjardins mais justement
ces jardins vous avez choisi on va en
parler tout faire mais ils ont tous une
âme en effet quelque chose ils reflètent
des personnalités c'est une aventure qui
a démarré il ya trois ans avec
donatienne de ces journées est l'auteur
du livre
alors il faut vraiment considérer que
dana sienne quand
l'ue a proposé ce squad éditeur à
proposer sujet donatienne avait dans le
jour même où elle a accepté le sujet je
crois que donatienne avait un fil
d'ariane dans l'esprit c'est à dire
qu'elle avait ce livre tout fait dans
son esprit elle savait exactement où
aller
voilà à quelques y il y avait des
arbitrages à faire sur des choix de
jardin mais elle avait une idée
extrêmement précises 1 de la ligne
complète du chemin de fer du ce qu'on
appelle un chemin de fer c'est à dire de
la ligne complète du livre ii du xviiie
siècle à nos jours parce que c'est un
livre qui reprend la thématique de la
chronologie s'il ya un fil conducteur
est la chronologie qui privilégie pas
démarre du 10 au xviiie siècle puisque
en fait la grande la grande culture
belge du jardin c'est à partir de
beloeil du prince de ligne de ces
terribles et se termine avec le 21e
siècle est très riche
ces 2 alors qu'elle m'a donné le 20 mai
il ya déjà un nombre important de jardin
qui ont été réalisés depuis 20 ans qui
sont dans le livre donc une grande
partie du livre pratique moins des trois
quarts sont consacrés au 20e siècle est
au 21ème siècle alors je reprends la
citation sur les sécateurs parce que
elle était amusante sur les coups de
sécateurs autres jardiniers ça n'existe
pas mais c'était une citation de pierre
vérité qui disait il fait aussi une
distinction et qui dit que c'est une
distinction éternelle entre les tenants
de la nature et les tenons de l'artifice
des les jardins qui sont naturels ou
déjà pas qu'ils sont travaillés qu'elle
est quelle est votre position là dessus
est ce qu est ce qu il faut être
dogmatique février rien il faut il faut
qu'il soit travailler où il faut qu'il
soit naturel ou est-ce qu'il faut
laisser la liberté à chacun d'apprécier
on souhaite un très vaste soleil moi je
viens d'un domaine où tous les styles de
jamin existe je me rends à versailles en
voilà tout à fait le journal à la
française voulu par louis xiv un journal
de pouvoir un jardin d'autorité qui est
en fait la mise en scène d'un
merveilleux réseau hydraulique et d'une
collection de statuaire unique au monde
et puis il y à marie antoinette qui elle
veut un jardin où elle puisse se sentir
libre
c'est le jardin paysager c'est le jardin
anglais c'est le jardin qui a pour objet
non pas de copier la nature mais de la
caricature et de la représenter non pas
telle qu'elle est mais tel qu'elle
aimerait que nous autres tel qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit voilà donc ce sont
ceux là qui finalement vont s'opposer
s'opposer en parfaite harmonie canton
et couvre la perspective voulue par le
14 et qu'ensuite on déambule dans les
allées du hameau de la reine
on n'est pas choqué la transition était
en douceur comme quoi un jardin quand il
est construit avec subtilité avec
intelligence peut accepter toutes les
contrariétés
il n'y a pas de guerre dans le domaine
gens là on devrait même échéance vous
pouvez même patrice pardon même faire
cette comparaison
le jardin est l'exemple même de
l'humanité exceptionnel on ne parle pas
ici de d'armes qui viennent de loin et
qui embête ceux qui sont originaires de
la région
l'introduction des jardins a montré que
quelle que soit sa couleur d'origine
on peut vivre ensemble le jardin en est
un parfait exemple pour vous donner un
exemple pour vraiment un exemple je suis
complètement à la vie dallas il s'est
trouvé que depuis quelques années que
j'habite cette propriété on y travaille
beaucoup
j'ai joué je suis aidé voilà je suis
aidé on y travaille beaucoup il y avait
une structure à laquelle d'ailleurs elle
a participé dans l'élaboration au départ
avec louis benech et quand je suis
arrivé ici
la structure était en place mais il y
avait tout un art n'a à recréer selon
mon goût on ya beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé et la chose merveilleuse qui
s'est passé pour pour donner un côté
positif à cet événement c'est qu'au
premier confinement des rois de mars
on s'en est plus occupé et que tout le
travail de deux 2 2 qui a été réalisée
ici de manucure pratiquement de taille
de replantation etc
abandonné pendant deux mois le jardin
n'a jamais été aussi charmant aussi beau
qu'à la sortie de ces deux mois de
confinement où vous l'avez ficher la
paix c'est vrai que c'est un donc voilà
ria bhl pour la nature un set j'ai même
une petite contrariété à ce sujet je le
dis avec humour
nous avons créé cette année un parterre
africains au grand écran par terre
aujourd'hui malheureusement démonter
mais qui fut sublime et puis nous avion
pour des raisons d'entretien d'effectifs
abandonné un peu comme ici le jardin
c'était le jardin des 4,9 à côté du gros
trio on avait donc décidé pendant deux
mois de ne pas y toucher
il s'avère que ce jardin structure et a
repris une certaine liberté
quelques fleurs qui se sont se met
naturellement se sont développées mais
les journalistes il préférait notre
jardin naturel
celui qui s'était développé tous ceux et
celles que le jardin construit parce que
la nature quand elle décide de nous
offrir ce qu'elle a de plus beau
elle est inégalable c'est absolument
sublime c'est cela d'ailleurs le danger
du jardin un jardin c'est un lieu que
l'on conçoit avec difficulté où il faut
être capable d'associer des végétaux de
différentes tailles de différentes
couleurs de différents volumes et puis
ensuite il faut l'entretenir et on a
souvent tendance à croire que dans le
jardin est laissé à lui même mais il
n'en est que plus beau oui
dans un premier temps après et en ré
attention cependant ce second jour car à
janin qui n'est plus entretenue et un
jardin qui meurt donc le jardin envoie
un malheureusement voilà temps en train
de regarder pendant les deux mois de
confinement chez césar le genre n'a été
en liberté mais liberté surveillée il
était quand même son contrôle ya une
phrase puisque parler de notre côté
donatienne jours-ci journée elle dit le
jardin c'est un monument mais c'est un
monument vivant
c'est une phrase très très belle et très
vrai quoi voilà parce qu'en fait c'est
je suis sûr qu'elle pensait
l'architecturé évidemment et qu'elle
faisait la différence entre
l'architecturé le jardin or le jardin
évidemment c'est un endroit d'abord où
les hommes viennent permanence pour
travailler pour renouveler pour affiner
pour replanter
en fait ces rapports et analyses et à
chaque fois de terre donc c'est un
renouveau permanent et c'est ce que je
pense que c'est ce que donatienne
voulais dire c'est à dire que il ya
cette espèce de déni d'ac2 dynamique que
donne de jardin et que donne la nature
avec le travail permanent qu'il faut
reconstituer et d'ailleurs tous ces gens
là bas âge qu'on a photographié c'est
ben c'est une merveille parce que ils
sont extrêmement élaboré et extrêmement
entretenu baye laye qui fait la
couverture du livre alors parler de
médaille parce qu'on parlait tous les
voilà depuis 2000 xviiie siècle tout ça
c'est ça continue d'être entretenue en
travaillé réfléchi re réfléchir on
réfléchis tout le temps à ce qu'un
ajustement alors rien il ya une sorte de
miracle dans votre livre parce que elle
a raison de dire c'est un monument
vivant donc qui évolue et la photo pour
l figé ce monument or non dans votre
livre justement la photographie ne fige
pas le jardin ouais enfin je sais pas
tendre
un moment voilà dans deux ans je suis
pas sûr que ça sera pas figé bon truc
vivons dans ce nid mais ce que j'ai
pensé ce que j'ai pensé pour un prochain
sujet quand même c'est de faire rentrer
dans les photos de jardin des
personnages voilà ça c'est important les
gains par deux essais pas vu des
quelques animaux c'est bien c'est pas
suffisant
je crois qu'il faut vraiment très
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de personnages
qui travaillent dans les jardins et des
animaux voilà ça sera ça c'est le
prochain
prochain objectif pour le prochain livre
voilà mais celui-là il vit alors c'est
un travail incroyable nous avons mis
trois ans à le réaliser il ya trente
deux jardins à plusieurs saisons à
plusieurs saisons ça l'idée alors
justement parlons des saisons à la barre
at on vous dit
il ya quand même une saison qui est
formidable c'est l'automne avant je
reconnais ma jalousie mais je vous avais
dit de vous parler d'eux justement ça
s'intéressent à leur sens quand vous
regardez le livre de césar est ce que
vous dites vous est admiratif vous êtes
vous tout à l'heure je rêvais d'être
photographe quand j'étais gamin je
voulais être photographe et l'idée que
l'on puisse être photographe de jardin
de ne veux pas penser quand j'étais
jeune aujourd'hui j'aurais peut-être
fait le travail que fait que fait césar
je vais juste un petit commentaire
césar était capable de saisir l'âme d'un
domaine qu'importe les personnages ou
pas ce que dit que ce n'était pas obligé
a effectivement pour répondre à votre
question
l'automne est la plus belle des saisons
pour quantité de raisons la première
c'est pour moi l'époque où les arbres
prennent enfin leurs vraies couleurs et
deviennent jaune orange rouge
ils prennent des teintes extraordinaire
mais c'est surtout l'époque où la nature
et surtout le gêner enfin peu non pas se
reposer
mécontent plus le travail effectué le
printemps l'été c'est la course on n'a
pas le temps n'a pas le temps de trop
réfléchir
il faut désherber il faut arroser il
faut planter il faut tailler c'est
beaucoup de travail
quand l'automne est là et encore du
travail mais il ya le divers qui va
arriver et qu'une enfin de repos là on
peut ce donc on est un peu comme des
artistes
on vient de jouer la pièce de théâtre on
peut enfin salué public en espérant bien
sûr que la pièce et qu'elle est un
succès donc j'aime la saison de
l'automne pour cette semaine
mais pour un autre motif également
certainement vous surprendre vous voir
vous amuser mais moi je vends dans un
domaine fréquenté tous les jours or
confinement bien sûr par des milliers de
visiteurs et il s'avère que quand on
vient à versailles c'est pour beaucoup
un jour de fête et on le combat rien
alors on vient avec les enfants les
dames mettent leurs plus belles
toilettes et les hommes sont très
élégants oui mais toutes ces couleurs
toutes ces points ces petites taches
jaunes orange rouge bleu dans les
jardins finissent par de temps en temps
non pas nuire à l'harmonie mais attiré
mon regard
laissez moi je préférais oms avait une
perspective où le reflet du g5 à
l'automne on est habillé un peu comme
nous l'a le personnage se font davantage
dans la nature
il accompagne le jardin il est en
parfaite harmonie et je trouve donc que
le jardin est beaucoup plus beau en
automne que le reste que le reste de
l'année
justement vous avez alors à rire des
saisons différentes et des heures
différents l'automne était très très
important parce qu'en fait moi j'avais
commencé par le printemps en particulier
dans des abris tom comme carotte ou
veste l'art qui sont très importants en
belgique
il faut vraiment noté l'importance des
collections d'arbres sur les collections
privées sur des particuliers qui sur
leur domaine collectionne des essences
d'arbres et j'avais commencé sur site
dans ces deux domaines en particulier
mais cela réclame tope là et près
d'anvers et lot d'épreuves bruxelles par
le printemps avec quand même des
collections de flore et des floraisons
extraordinaire sur des arbres
c'est à dire des magnolias précoce qui
fleurissent avant l'apparition du
feuillage et ces rapts dire juste à la
fin de l'hiver
et lorsque je suis hélas je partage toit
dans la vie dallas lorsque je suis
retourné dans ces domaines à l'automne
c'était absolument magique d'une pas et
surtout surtout c'est que l'automne ne
pardonne rien c'était que quand l'autre
quand le jardin est beau à l'automne ça
veut dire qu'il a subi un travail
permanent depuis la fin de l'hiver et
qu'on l'a entretenue qu'on l'a quand
l'automne c'est un résultat voilà c'est
une espèce de finalité et je suis je
partage complètement la vie la vie
d'anna là dessus et alors il est où ton
mais il ya des heures aussi parce que
oui ou non quand vous vous parti de chez
vous
alors ça c'est une vraie aventure j'ai
fait de la photographie comme on fait
une partie on joue une partie de tennis
il faut aller vite de l'énergie conduire
sa voiture arriver à l'heure la veille
au soir dans un hôtel au bord de
l'autoroute je voulais deux jours moi je
prenais des rendez vous je voyais
personne et je travaillais dans une
interview au figaro
vous avez dû rencontrer bonnes jambes et
de normes moi j'ai une personne c'était
trop compliqué on arrive la veille au
soir
j'ai fait 350 kilomètres je suis
concentré
le lendemain matin je me lève à 5h
pourrait dans la propriété le seul
numéro de téléphone que j'ai cessé le
domaine c'est le gardien qui va ouvrir
le portail et je suis là le soleil va se
lever j'arrive une heure avant et je
repère dans le noir où je repère pas du
tout et je ne peux pas parler je peux
il fallait que je sois concentration et
donc et puis et puis c'est la joie de
mon métier c'était la joie mon métier
c'est de cette cette solitude cc matin
de courir comme ça dans un jeu dans une
propriété à toute allure pour être à
tous les endroits en même temps ce que
gvt à 20 minutes une demi heure trois
quart d'heure de belles lumières quand
c'est grand et quand ces grands il faut
courir dans tous les sens quand on a le
goût musical 2 1
voilà avec mon escabeau montrés prêts et
mon aimons et mon appareil
alors que voilà tu es un modèle
répondait nous un peu cette belgique
desjardins vous aviez déjà consacré un
livre à l'italie voilà des jardins on a
l'impression que chez les belges et un
peu toutes les influences qui sont
arrivés là les belges se sont non non
non pas une stylistique particulier à
desjardins belge covial desjardins
italiens les jardins à la française les
jardins anglais mais les belges on tue
une chose ils ont fait une synthèse très
intéressante
c'est un peuple cosmopolite qui a
beaucoup pas cueilli qui a beaucoup
voyagé d'une part et puis ils ont
possédé le congo et avec des rois qui
ont avec un roi leopold qui a adoré la
dendre logique collectionner les arbres
et les plantes et les belges se sont
inspirées à la fois des français des
italiens et des anglais et ils en ont
fait une synthèse
d'abord ils ont un climat est une terre
parfaite et énormément de goût ils ont
en fait une synthèse très intéressante
qui n'est ni française ni tagliani
i anglaise mais belge mais intéressant
2010 bernard oui j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention parce que le prince
de ligne qui fut l'un des grands des
grands jardiniers du xviiie siècle dans
cette théorie écrivait justement qu
importe le style que le jardin soit la
française ou à l anglaise ce qui compte
c'est qu'il soit beau et finalement les
solutions qu'apporte le 6 mai 20 soit
beau et je crois que j'ai un sombre
wayana que j'aime particulièrement en
belgique car je ne parle pas des jardins
qui appartenait à la famille royale qui
sont situés les serres là on le fait on
va en reparler
le jardin de beloeil voilà c'est un
jardin qui est là qui figurent à la fois
dans le livre de césar garçons et dans
votre livre alain baraton 1
pourquoi alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
associent particulier c'est un condensé
en fait c'est le jardin que je ne
qualifierais pas la française mais de
style régulier qui annonce déjà la
fantaisie du style irrégulier il ya du
le notre idée du ruisseau dans la
conception
j'aime également quand on parle de
philosophie c'est un jardin qui
s'adresse autant aux regards qu'à
l'intelligence c'est un jardin qui a une
âme quand on est à beloeil con quand on
regarde ce lieu quand on s'y promène on
est on est quelque part c'est vous à peu
près beloeil alors là je peux pas dire
je vais y aller avec un gps
en revanche il fait la couverture du
livre puisqu'il est à l'origine des gens
et ce qui est formidable fait d'apartés
c'est que ça appartient toujours aux
lignes michel deligne s'en occupe
aujourd'hui auto si bien que son aïeul
c'est formidable s'est plaint de la
morale ah oui tout à fait l'oci ucip ya
été d un kaki ségolène mais l'agitateur
c'est un homme qui ne s'est pas
simplement contenté de créer un jour là
il a jeté les bases du style de jardin
un jardin ce n'est pas qu'un assemblage
de végétaux c'est une harmonie
c'est une philosophie et un jardin d'eau
bien à quelques règles
on oublie trop souvent que andré le
nôtre que je connais bien n'a rien
inventé
andré le nôtre n'est qu'un conservant
quand c'est un con non pas qu'un mais un
concepteur de gens là la française qui a
duré mais avant lui il y avait jacques
androuet du cerceau y avait la famille
molex
établi les principes mêmes du genre à la
française ce qui ont établi que les
allées de m
perpendiculaire ou parallèles qui a
défini les perspectives d'emploi y est
les hommes de charmilles roulait lui ce
sont les mollets ce sont les boîtes de
la raudière et bien la morale c'est la
même chose c'est un homme qui était
capable de donner des principes pour 15
jours soit réussie un jardin c'est
quelque chose de difficile à faire
admettons je vous donne à vous un
tableau avec quelques pinceau un
chevalet et une toile je suis pas sûr de
ce que vous allez faire serait exposé de
masse et passionnant plus jamais la même
chose cette année
c'est une discipline qui demande de la
rigueur du bout de la patience et de la
connaissance
eh bien les gens comme la morale comme
mollet comme comme ont contribué à une
fois de plus je rejoins là parce que
voilà la présence des créateurs dans les
journaux c'est très important et c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'a voulu faire dans la
sienne de séjourner en rende hommage à
des créateurs contemporains y en a deux
en particulier
rené cher très important qui n'est pas
très connu en france bien qu'il ait fait
il réalisait des jardins privés dans le
nord de la france mais c'est surtout
celui qui a créé l'école d'horticulture
de bruxelles celui qui a recréé qui a
recréé des jardins après la guerre après
45 pour des reconstructions et qui a
fait dans certaines propriétés anciennes
18e
desjardins qui post post des années
50-60 très intéressant personnages
auxquels on a rendu à hama et un autre
qui est mort pendant la réalisation du
livre qu'est jacques wirtz et qui était
un monsieur merveilleux que j'ai connu
et dont le fils les fils peter et son
frère nous ont autorisés à photographier
le jardin évidemment en hommage au père
mort pendant la réalisation du livre
oui il faut dire pardon excusez moi à la
fois il ya quelques jardins qu'on peut
aller visiter de temps en fonction il
s'est peu ouverts et beaucoup de jardins
combat alors qu' il faut leur et de les
voir dans le livre parce qu'on peut pas
y aller voilà mais je pense afin de
naviguer nage par exemple via une page
consacrée aux jardins ouverts
que j'en ai visitables on peut aussi les
visiter ce qui devrait visiter pendant
les journées des jardins pages qui sont
un événement qui a lieu au printemps et
yade a quand même pas mal qui sont
ouverts ou verts ouvrent à eau visitable
aussi sur rendez vous donc on peut les
voir on peut les voir quand même des
jardins tous et ont privé tout sauf à un
mot sur justement sur le parce que ce
qu'on disait au début il ya eu une
progression historique dans votre livre
ça finit par les jardins de canal de
dons s'élevaient voilà voilà
est ce qu'on peut faire dd je vous pose
la question détruit de légèreté moderne
est ce qu'ils peuvent être beau est-ce
que c'est différent
ah oui jardin urbain léger enfin très
inquiet lorsque je dis bien sûr n'engage
que moi mais je dis souvent que les gens
là à la française ceux de louis xiv sont
des voisins qui ont pour objet de
montrer le pouvoir
le manager nature ce sont des gens n'a
d'autorité et je constate qu'aujourd'hui
les jardins modernes sont des jardins
basée sur le réalisme sur le minéral
ce sont des gens là qui ne sont
peut-être pas à la française mais qui
sont de style très régulier et je trouve
que ce genre-là n'annonce rien rien de
bon j'aime l'idée qu'un jardin
permettent à des enfants de s'égarer
parce que j'ai envie dans un jardin
c'est de pouvoir rêver et beaucoup de
jardins mais d'un pas tous à tous
beaucoup ne me font pas rêver les crêtes
il ya quand même des créateurs
contemporains des paysagistes qui sont
des jardins de charme quand même louis
benech réalise des ninjas cette femme
cette femme en amérique
madame von fin de galles fait des faits
des jardins merveilleux pas du tout fort
mal
le landais comment s'appelle-t-il le
type qui fait des prairies la fef et des
jardins très très très poétique
donc il faut en mousse sur la côte
d'azur
voilà ce qui fait des jardins très beau
et c'est même plus desjardins qui lie ce
sont des paradis
l'hollandais ça fait tout drôle ça c'est
important de le dire pitof mais écrit et
créé des recrues des prêts et des
prairies donc à chacun aujourd'hui quand
même il ya une poésie contemporaine qui
ce qui est qui qui ce qui ressort de
tout ça est depuis longtemps parce que
on prend les jardins de jacques
majorelle au maroc comprend plaindre il
faut bien sûr tout ça tout ça a un
charme fou quand même donc dans votre
dictionnaire amoureux illustrer un
embarras tôt vous dites
et c'est vrai qu'il est difficile
d'imaginer qu'au début du 20e siècle la
la banlieue parisienne et est un haut
lieu de la production agricole
c'est ce que savait est ce que cette
avancée de la ville au fond sur les
jardins vous fait ou sur la nature vous
vous fait un peu peur oui bien sûr ce
mais il est vrai ce que vous dites la
première région viticole de richard
vient les abris les pêches que l'on
mangé en région parisienne et encore 150
ans était produit à montreuil à deux pas
d'ici bien évidemment le long les fameux
mur et ce sont les seuls c'est
finalement le train clé mais tout s'est
tous ces produits tout c'est doré à la
portée de tout le monde qui a détruit
mais effectivement le jardin a réussi à
lutter pendant quelques siècles à une
urbanisation console et la disparue au
détriment de la construction de quelques
tours à femmes
mais le jardin est en train de revenir
je découvris ya pas longtemps
la ville de quimper mais j'ai été
abasourdi par la beauté des jardins de
cette ville qui sont en train de
renaître la ville de paris à elle seule
possède 500 jardins qui sont en train
d'être j'allais dire réhabiliter
replants restaurer plus magnifiques les
uns que les autres donc le jardin est en
train de reprendre sa revanche
le vingtième siècle n'était pas le cas
les gens là souvenez vous la chanson de
dutronc d' avec les un petit jardin qui
sentait bon on sait ce qu'il est devenu
métropolitain et bien ça y est c'est le
retour des jardins c'est le retour des
senteurs c'est le retour des fleurs et
c'est est urgentissime quand on voit la
paille dans laquelle nous visons ok
quand même assez anxiogène
là on est ici dans un monde sans masque
prions prions pour que demain à
l'extérieur on puisse cesser d'en porter
et bien le jardin c'est peut-être que là
nous sauver parce que je ne vois pas du
tout quelles sont les yeux aujourd'hui
où l'on peut cheval en ville se promener
en toute liberté
si c'était dans un jardin est là il ne
reste malheureusement très peu de temps
tellement ça passe vite tellement vous
êtes vous est passionnant alors il
faudrait et l'autre point commun le but
dictionnaire de dallas aimons et monuc
sur la belgique
c'est les alignements et l'aiderait
belge les rêves alors que c'était les
brèves
alors ça c'est une chose c'est le mode
raid couvert le c'est une chose c'est un
belgicismes et ses rêves en fait voilà
bref et de drive en anglais et c'est un
belge ici ça n'existe pas en français et
ce mot de rêve quand je les entends
l'épreuve première fois ils
correspondent à une réalité c'est à dire
que le pays est sillonnée sur les
perpendiculaire des routes par des
grands allée d'arbres qui mène soit
modeste ou noble qui mène soit des
châteaux soit des fermes
elles sont plus belles les unes que les
autres et elles sont surtout tellement
nombreuses car les gedia donatienne tu
sais pour un français comme moi qui voit
le long des routes toutes ces allées
toutes ces allées qui mène aux demeures
ou aux propriétés il faut qu'on en parle
dans le livre et on a fait quatre pages
on a pu en être consacré quatre pages
aux rêves que je connais que j'ai
photographié dans toutes les propriétés
et condom en a fait une sorte de
synthèse comme ça et ça correspond aux
alignements dont parle dans la lettre a
à présent deux ans a beaucoup de
l'alignement
la photo qui illustre la vie devant elle
elle représente le canal du midi
c'est un alignement en courbe je voulais
montrer que la ligue est trop court il
ya d'autres choses à 20 alors il ya
évidemment le désert de red j'aurais
voulu qu'on en parle parce que ça
c'est pas très loin d'ici mais nous
sommes prêts à revenir
oui c'est vrai que vouliez mettre un
géant un jardin d'essai m à l'extrémité
du passé mais attention je parle d'un
ange est en outre en tout 40 pb lotus
est leur le voit de partout c'est génial
ça vous une idée on aurait pris au jeu
sur minable césar garçons aussi c'est un
livre absolument sublime la belgique
desjardins et puis le dictionnaire
amoureux illustré desjardins merci
infiniment ces organes sont
personnalisés merci à vous
il
[Musique]